franchement je n'arrête pas de jouer à
angry birds sur mon iphone 4s
j'suis trop un geek quoi c'est quoi
cette mode du geek sérieux d'où ça sort
c'est pas parce que tu passes ton temps
sur facebook que tu as aimé le dernier
harry potter que tu es un geek c'est pas
ça un geek c'est quelqu'un d'avant tous
deux passionnés qui vit pour ses
passions comme la science fiction
les nouvelles technologies
l'informatique alors comme ça devient un
petit peu n'importe quoi moi c'est mes
nouvelles lunettes ouais c'est mon petit
côté geek tu vois
[Musique]
je vais passer en revue quelques
éléments qui peuvent déterminer si oui
ou non vous êtes un geek c'est un geek
quand tu peux pas rester tranquille avec
un mec à côté de toi qui utilisent un
ordinateur une fois par an f a
maintenant bien sûr on est comme on est
face à des taux non non non non non
comme on efface là dessus je sais je
sais voilà ça va si bien
oui oui j'ai l'impression que tu es bon
ça va bien non donc tu es un geek quand
tous les gens autour de toi te prennent
pour super informaticien un citoyen tu
peux m'installer à l'antivirus tu peux
défragmenter mon personnage me conseille
d'acheter comme télévision tu peux
réparer mon ordinateur j'ai là trombone
une ficelle
tu peux me construire un hélicoptère ça
veut dire oui tu es un geek quand tu
préfères compte arrache les ongles un
parent lentement plutôt que de recevoir
une chaîne de mails de tes parents alors
mon chéri tu as aussi mon mail avec le
powerpoint marenla qu'il envoyait tout
les amis maman j'ai un truc à te prendre
ta des super pouvoirs
ah bon oui tu sais volée vas-y elle sait
il saute par la fenêtre
d'accord je bats ça c'est fait tu es un
geek
si tu ne vas jamais sur les sites pornos
tout cas c'est ce qu'on peut croire en
regardant ton historique
c'est un geek camp dès qu'un truc
electronics or il faut que tu l'achètes
comme par exemple un livre électronique
1la 2000 livres qui tiennent là dedans
c'est génial ce truc ensuite faut pas
que ça te dérange si chez toi ça passe
de ça
ah ça non
tu es un geek il ya un truc qui t'énerve
mais tellement c'est quand tu es
tranquillement quand ton ordinateur
le temps en train de regarder une vidéo
ma foi plutôt sympathique mais que top
stop stop
le bruit du chat facebook c'est moi une
petite blague je suis sûr qu'elle n'a
plein d'entre vous qui était kim
kyoung-hui qui me parle oui facebook non
non les personnes qui me parlent kg
c'est ça sort d'où il faut qu'on trouve
un métier - tu es un geek quand parfois
tu as envie de faire contrôler l'aide
dans la vraie vie il arrive très souvent
ça
[Musique]
et voilà c'est un garçon il est si beau
je vais l'appeler cortex et voilà c'est
un garçon il est si beau si tu réunis
toutes ces conditions alors tu fais
partie de la confrérie des geeks dans le
cas contraire tu fais partie des autres
instagram
ça fait au moins une semaine que je
connais déjà instagram
tu parles d'un geek là alors tu
t'ennuies et tu peux voir toutes mes
autres vidéos
enfin sur cyprien point fr
91 les pyramides